l'albero è bello però bisogna
spolverarla le palline perché se non
perde tutta la sua bellezza la sua
luminosità è di come sono tutte più
belle rispolverata tutt'altra cosa
[Musica]
ma guarda questo specchio quanta polvere
l'ho visto in tempo tra due aree
arrivano tutti i parenti che vergogna
allora ricapitoliamo il 24 pranzo siamo
dare una sala per la vigilia abbiamo da
0 30 mentre natale siamo da mamma quindi
devo preparare tutto 24 pomeriggio in
modo tale che quando lui si ritira il
panettone artigianale mentre io sarò
breve creatrice per i miti quando sarò
il taglio il rosso per i 25 abito in
chiffon i regali li ho fatti già ottobre
quindi sono posso mamma ma cosa ci fai
ancora sveglia sono le 4 del mattino
gioia mia
pensi che il pranzo di domani si cucini
da solo
io non andrò a dormire perché diamo
cucinare 18 piatti e pensa sono tutte le
ricette che ha impegnato la tua bisnonna
altro gastronomia
non ho che cos'è tutta questa roba è le
lucine tutte le lucine sembra di essere
a las vegas pure lo gnomo
ma che cos'è il fantabosco dico io e
basta io mi ribello tutto l'anno lo
merita trovare a natale i bambini tanti
auguri che bene notare l'alberello basta
io quest'anno niente regali neanche per
te caro neanche per te cara famiglia non
c'è momento migliore del santo natale
per ringraziare gesù cristo nostro
signore
quindi prima di iniziare il nostro
pranzo di natale vorrei che tutti
insieme ci prendessimo per mano così
bravi e formarsi un grande cerchio
grande come il bene che ci pone il
nostro signore
grande come il regno dei cieli e
ripetessimo tutti insieme grazie signore
grazie grazie a un attimo di attenzione
e jingjing belle jing tu scendi dalle
stelle ore del ceno senti di questa
domenica ma basta poi ho stonato
guarda che divertente che simpatica
questa campanellina stop perfetto potere
qui mica posso lasciarlo così punto
possiamo mettere innanzitutto questa
ghirlanda
in mezzo ci mettiamo lo gnomo così
bambini sono felice però manca ancora
qualcosa manca qualcosa faccia qualcosa
ma le lucine ovvio può di qui poi lo
giriamo così meraviglioso che tocco di
classe
no guarda cara quest'anno sono piena di
appuntamenti da far schifo ma so
lavorando guarda come noi di natale ma
io non ho fatto i regali ecco perché
c'erano tutti quegli alberi in giro le
lucine lati giuro che non capivo ma
guarda che testo che ormai sono fuse
certo caramella però passo subito che ti
voleva salutare sabò salvatore vella
uniche finanzia dall'australia sbrigati
e spesso di un sacco di soldi a rosario
sono al telefono con carmela la vuoi
salutare certo che problema c'è carmela
ti metto subito al telefono con rosario
vi sentite vi sentite guai a voi sapete
regali e toglie aver immediatamente con
le scarpe che da stamattina che
puliscono e per favore fatemi la
cortesia bambini mi raccomando se andate
a giocare in giardino non calpestate le
mie piante ed è perché sono niente
regali andate subito a mettere laica
questo video è non mi fate arrabbiare e
iscrivetevi al canale mi raccomando
[Musica]